if one wishes to find the gold of life
they must be willing to dig and sift
through the dirt when thinking about
life becomes very easy to drown in its
immense complexity and uncertainty
becomes appealing to just claim
ignorance and pretend like such
complexity does not exist but pretending
that life is simple does not make it so
regardless of how much one may try no
one can be completely numb to the
effects of life the only real way to
simplify life is by following it down
its path of complexity we must not run
from its intricate and elusive nature we
must instead accept and embrace it
consider the basic food ingredient a
tomato think how many edible
applications there are for a tomato you
can eat it whole you can cut it up into
big chunks and put it on a salad you can
slice it into small slivers and put it
on a burger you can dice it or put it in
soup or on top of a chicken meal you can
smash it up and make it into a sauce for
a pasta meal or pizza you can blend it
with the addition of other ingredients
and make it into ketchup or a soup broth
the recipes and applications for a
tomato are endless but one can only
uncover them if they break the tomato
down the more one breaks it down into
smaller and smaller pieces the more
usages the tomato has and the easier it
is to manipulate into different meals
life works the same way individuals who
are willing to cut up break down and
analyze complicated thoughts and ideas
are able to turn them into delicious
in the form of solutions art or
understanding all things in life do not
require / complication but it is the
fear of facing the things that do that
prevents legitimate simplification and
well-being it is this fear that leaves
us hopelessly lost from who we can be
and what we can experience in life
it is this fear that we must overcome it
is the tomato that we must cut through
you
[Music]